hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein lieblingsrezept von
samira und zwar mache ich eine
champignon creme suppe
passend zu meinem ramadan special und
die champignon creme suppe besteht
wirklich nur aus ganz wenigen zutaten
sie schmeckt wirklich richtig toll nach
champignons und ich zeige euch mal eben
für die suppe brauche ich 40 gramm
butter 40 kommune 500 milliliter wasser
250 milliliter milch 100 milliliter
sahne pfeffer einen teelöffel salz 250
gramm braune champignons etwas
petersilie und eine bedrohung sein muss
ich eine mehlschwitze herstellen das
heißt aus butter und mehl
deswegen gebe ich jetzt die partei in
einen kleinen topf und erhitzen sie habe
ich das mir dazu nicht ein bisschen
angebraten und zehen gebräunt und jetzt
nicht zu braunen werden lassen
also hier brauchen das wird umso
intensiver wir da noch der geschmack
also finde ich auch sehr gut jetzt mit
wasser ablöschen
da kann auch direkt sahne und wenn ich
mit ein
und dann darf die vermischung erstmal
aufkochen und ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit die champignons klein
schneiden
nachdem
die suppe dürfte jetzt etwa 5 minuten
kochen und mit der kochgruppe kocht
übrigens nicht überall so wenn ihr keine
kupplung ab müsste auf jeden fall beim
herd stehen bleiben und eventuell den
herd runterschalten sonst passiert euch
das was mir gestern auch passieren
jetzt kommen die champignons direkt mit
rein und wir müssen dann auch wirklich
nur 45 minuten mitgekocht werden
es gebe ich auch direkt ist alles nicht
dazu und pfeffer und gleich noch einen
spaß ist ohne saft
kennen wir das zwischenzeit schon mal
die täter sehr fein hacken
wieso bist jetzt kocht man kann sich
natürlich so lassen wobei die
champignons wirklich noch sehr groß sind
und die konsistenz jedoch wirklich
besser wenn man sie püriert oder mixed
und ich mixe dem mac network blender
aber ein pürierstab geht natürlich auch
und da können jetzt bestimmen ob es
jetzt ganz fein haben wollt oder ein
bisschen stück ich und ich werde jetzt
ganz fein machen und habe aber auch noch
ein paar champignons entscheiden
geschnitten und die kommen danach kommt
noch mit dazu
zürich die suppe noch mal in den topf
zurück können sie nochmal ganz recht
erhalten
denn jetzt geht noch wie champignons in
scheiben mit dazu und dann finde ich
kann sie bereits anrichten
die suppe sind fertig und die samira
darf probieren denn das ist deine
lieblingspuppe gern und ich führe die
suppe immer ganz fallen weil sie mir
artig stückchen nicht mag und diese
großen scheiben kann sie ihren ein fleck
fischen ganz gespannt
normalerweise würde ich jetzt die
petersilie bestreuen mehr haben wir
nicht dass es nicht also darf so etwas
so probieren aber posten okay man ihm am
besten von außen oder von oben und dann
kann's immer posten gerne und dann darf
man den urteil abgeben wie die suppe
schmeckt
und los
und schmeckt so gut echt jetzt deine
lieblingssuppe entschuldigung ist falsch
macht jetzt ich oben ankam ihrer
schmeckt die suppe ist sehr gut die ist
jetzt auf die suppe recht als
hauptgericht für etwa drei personen als
vorspeise für locker vier bis fünf
personen
falls ihr sehen wollt geht aufs eis -
blog.de da steht es noch mal ganz genau
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und einen guten appetit bis
zum nächsten mal
macht das rezept nach und teil teuer
foto auch unserer facebook oder
instagram seite mit dem hashtag bmg
sally